I got asked to speak at this like
personal trainer conference and he's
like yeah I blocked 4 hours for you
that's a lot I had such a long speaking
slot that I was like well I'm not going
to pitch for 4 hours I I made this
really long presentation that was just
like very very good on Fitness sales and
marketing all that kind of stuff at the
end I was like yeah and here's the prize
and I dropped it and so I did what would
have been a 90-minute presentation pitch
in like 15 minutes after giving 3 hours
plus of value and I got so much
resistance from the crowd I think I made
two sales like it was nothing the moral
of the story though I had done a half
measure and so it's either sell or don't
so